[Musique]
l'utilisation du 49 3 en pleine crise du
coronavirus est en pleine campagne des
municipales marquera de manière
indélébile ce quinquennat
cela signifie que cette réforme qui
déterminera l'avenir de millions de
français sur des décennies ne sera pas
votée à l'assemblée nationale ni en
commission spéciale ni en séance
publique
cela signifie que des questions
complexes et potentiellement redoutable
comme la fixation de la valeur du point
la mise en place d'une super décote la
prise en compte de la pénibilité
n'auront jamais pu être évoqué au fond
vous avez encouragé l'obstruction puis
activer le 49-3 pour éviter d' expliquer
votre réforme pour en masquer les
lacunes
ça devait être la mère de toutes les
réformes c'est du moins ce que nous
avait promis le président de la
république emmanuel macron de piles
olympe
mais voilà la rentrée de cette réforme
dans l'atmosphère a été terriblement
dégrisante pas une seule et a pas un
seul étage sans un ratage
les deux première année studieuse de
monsieur delevoye pour rien l'avis du
conseil d'état cruel le débat à
l'assemblée nationale
escamoté mais après tout monsieur le
premier ministre comment vous en vouloir
vous vous occupez à la fois des
retraites d'une crise sanitaire mondiale
et d'une campagne électorale les
français sont inquiets et attendre
légitimement que leur chef de
gouvernement soient totalement mobilisée
au service de l'intérêt national
aujourd'hui on est confronté bien
entendu à une multiplication des foyers
du coran navires russes en provenance de
chine
nouvellement identifiés qui affecte
plusieurs continents sur le territoire
est aujourd'hui je prends environ 200
cas donc quatre malheureux décès prévoir
et se préparer c'est indispensable et
nécessaire
vous avez oublié les premiers de cordée
et les premiers de cordée ce sont les
médecins libéraux
les hospitaliers les infirmiers les
pompiers
les visiteurs d pad les visiteurs à
domicile et cela ne sont pas là nous
faisons face à une crise dans la crise
à l'hôpital l'hôpital c'est un peu comme
votre gouvernement
quand ceux qui sont en première ligne
sont épuisées il y a de moins en moins
de monde en deuxième ligne pour prendre
le relais temps vous avez assécher les
territoires entre la gestion des
patients courant l'intensification des
urgences le besoin d'espacé isolé
d'accueil pour les patients touchés les
français s'inquiètent de voir nos grands
hôpitaux démunis face à la probable
épidémie postes non pourvus garde à
rallonge personnel en souffrance c'est
toujours la réalité dans nos
établissements de santé malgré vos
mesures d'urgence cette crise ne va
faire qu'aggraver la violence des
déserts médicaux là où les uns après les
autres les hôpitaux de proximité sont
torpillé par le pouvoir central
selon toute vraisemblance ils sont plus
d'un million plus d'un million qu'ils
soient écoliers collégiens ou lycéens
vivra calvaire quotidien dans leur
établissement scolaire mais également en
dehors
ils ce sont les jeunes victimes du
harcèlement scolaire
les chiffres sont effrayants en moyenne
trois enfants par classe vite victime d'
attaques verbales physiques ou
psychologiques
alors pour protéger nos enfants pour
éviter à de nouvelles familles d'en
passer par ce drame il faut agir
[Musique]